not sure if it was cheating or Polly
well it's because it's because of what
Jada chose to put on red table talk yeah
but Choice again think of like celebrity
I find it so strange I'm like but it's
the same thing if you if you like it
might happen on a like the reason we
look at Celebrities is because they
represent like our normal life so like
like for example I know a lot of guys
that have trouble in like custody like
getting custody of the kids and so when
Kanye was going through that it kind of
represents like part of like a problem
in society because if a billionaire
can't get custody of his kids like what
does that say about Society right same
thing like if if you wife a 304 that
like talks
right um online it might not happen at
like a global scale but like you can
still embarrass your dude in your
community you know what I'm saying like
it might it might not happen at that big
of a level but these people like they
represent what's happening in society
just at like a global scale does that
make sense yeah I suppose I just I
actually respect them for the fact that
um I mean she wouldn't speak on it on a
podcast
unless he was happy for her to do so I
think we we could all agree that they
have a stable enough relationship
oh my God no she she just said that she
didn't agree with the slab no no no no
I'm saying is in I when they talk about
when she talks about like the the kind
of sexual relationships that they have
and like their open relationship and
things when she's spoken on that right
they have they had they had August on
red table talk who's August
eventually cheated with like 20 years
younger but interesting I'll be honest I
think is going to do whatever she wants
to do but yeah I think my point is like
I I
in a sense respect the fact that
these people
regardless of what people think of Jada
because I think she gets a lot of flack
I don't know all of the inside of Goss
by the way I'm up with other yeah but I
think that I respect them for the fact
that will is a is is clearly standing up
and saying actually no we have this kind
of relationship or you know we've we've
had a bit of an open relationship and I
still love my wife and things and I
think okay fair enough regardless of
what I think of the dynamic of your
relationship I appreciate the fact that
that this person is going I still stand
with my wife I think that's I think
that's I don't know he's a good thing
but I think you know like going back to
the original point I think that I think
it's just a I think it's just a bit of a
shame that like that that we view how
like the the way that we
view our respect of men versus women
that it's that it's not a similar thing
in the in the art respect of men is is
deemed on you know
respectable things like you know are you
intelligent you know are you ambitious
these good qualities and and women are
reduced down to have you slept with lots
of men well it's not reduced down to
it's like that's easier you're much
harder it is to be a dude you just have
to not get fat okay as a girl not get
fat not sleep with too many people and
you'll you'll find a husband but like
man if they want to get a woman they
have to make a lot of money they have to
go to the gym they have to like there's
a long list of [__] that like women look
for I think guys do too and I think it's
I think as we move away that's not true
that's not true no because statistically
like like if you if you survey in women
like I could point out study after study
after study showing you that's not true
because if you look at dating app swipes
men swipe right like 50 of the time and
on top of that like they surveyed men if
you go on a first date with a girl she
has 80 of the things you look for would
you go on a second date men said yes
women said no like women are pickier
it's much harder for a man to like get
girls than it is for girls to get guys
even even as even in commitment terms
yeah I think in terms of on the surface
level of what what do people want and
again going back to that thing of
abundance yeah but I think
every guy I know every single like guy
who I go oh we're friends we're these
are these are guys who I really respect
none of them like of course they could
go okay yeah I would maybe swipe right
on her but none of them would stay if
she had no personality no ambition no
Hobbies no interest sure I agree sure a
guy a guy with options you're correct
like the guys that can will but like my
point is like we're complaining about
this double standard right but it's like
it's not even that bad to be honest it
might like I think it's a much harder
for men on the other end because they
have to like build up to be something
that women want unless you're just born
really good looking and tall
I think some men are lucky
shout out to Chris what
you even said it yourself when when you
came to my channel you said when you're
dating apps like you look at most of the
guys you go oh yeah like with most girls
you can see something attractive that
you go yeah go on a date with you you
look at the guys and you're like most
guys you're like what the [__] is this
you even said that so it's like
and so here's a question do you think
you apply a different standard to men
than you do to women
when you're dating them no I think it's
a thing of am I
do they have a good personality are they
physically attractive I I look for the
same things the same traits but I think
my my point when we were speaking before
is I think there are objectively more
pretty women in the world than there are
good looking men so do you like a guy
who's taller than you
and we also spoke about this and I again
I've dated people who were short like
someone who was actually shorter than me
and I've dated people who are all [__]
like would you prefer a guy who's taller
okay fine don't cap like what I mean
imagine you've got you've got the guy
who's got amazing personalities right
there's one version of him where he's
six foot one and there's one version of
him when he's five foot four who are you
gonna choose that's actually that's a
really interesting question are you
saying it has no bearing I actually
don't know no I actually don't know do
you care if a girl's taller than you
I actually prefer girls who are taller
than me yeah you do I actually prefer
taller girls yeah have you dated more
you're in luck
I tend to prefer girls who are taller
than me maybe I would with guys say that
maybe if that was a side by side and I
don't think and I don't think it's a bad
thing because you know I've got quite a
few friends who are bi as well and it's
like they they probably they apply a
different standard to men than they do
for women and I think
ugly I would agree I do I I would say
this is more attractive girls than guys
yeah
um but there is a burden there is a
higher burden of performance on men in
terms of to in terms of being attractive
in general in comparison to women find
80 of men unattractive
yeah I can I can relate to that yeah if
you find 80 of women unattractive
no but then I feel like my attraction to
women is
but do you see what I'm saying when I'm
saying like it's much harder for men in
dating like in just like oh like yeah so
for sure in terms of like and again
talking about like apartments and things
like that I think
because if there are all of these pretty
women and I think they go oh my God
here's the he's the top guy I think for
sure but I think we've done a lot as
reducing it down to dating apps but then
so then could you understand like when
men like really don't have a ton of
standards that it's okay like like that
they might say like that that's a
standard for them is that either a low
body count or no only ends yeah and
again like I completely I'm like if
that's if that for you is a deal breaker
I respect that that's fine you're
allowed to have that opinion but for me
it's just more about but why do you have
that opinion one in one in three men are
either a virgin or haven't had sex in
the last year I think that's under those
isn't it
one in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the past year
that's brutal yeah that's brutal I'm
gonna read some super chats really